(chant autochtone)
- Des chants et du tambour
en plein coeur de Rome
du moment.
La procession est solelelele;
l'émotion est palpable.
- Right at this moment,
- La cheffe de la communauté
de Tk'emlups se sent prête.
Après des années d'attente
et une
par la COVID, c'est enfin au
tour des délégués des Prres
Nations de se rendre au Vatican
pour y rencontrer le pape.
La patience des survivants
des pensionnats a finalementonoe
avec le pape François a duré
deux
que prévu. Que ce soit pour
décrire les abus physiques
et sexuels ou les tentatives
d'effacer leur identité,
prendre le temps d'expliquer
au chef de l'Église catholique
toute la douleur causée
par les
Mais de ce sombre récit
dedededede ce sombre récit
semble avoir rejailli
une certaine lumiprprprprprprpre
dans la célèbre peinture
qui orne la chapelle Sixtine.
Le pape François semble
l'importance de ces témoignages
pour les délégués.
MANDY GULL-MASTY, grande cheffe
Grand Conseil des Cris du Québec
réconciliation, même, il a dittr
en prière pour nous répondre
demain, puis je pense que
la délégation est vraiment
aujourd'hui.
- Le pape n'a pas didididididice
sur les mots qu'il prononceradie
d'excuses, les Premières Nations
seraient près du but.
Il a écouté les délégués
et c'est finalement demain
e e e e e e prendra la parole.
Après des années d'attente,
on verra enfin si 'E'E'E'E'E'EÉq